hi there steve kaufman here um
we finished our first hangout i'm
getting the hang of the hangouts
uh and i think it was successful uh and
i want to learn from it
so i would look forward to any comments
or suggestions
uh a few things that i would like to do
and i'd like your reaction to this
uh first of all uh
i would like to know what subjects
you're interested in talking about in
future hangouts
which languages you want to participate
in
and what time slots work best
one of the problems this time was trying
for me having to choose who was going to
be the active who are going to be the
active participants
there were comments on our link page at
google google plus
some of them weren't clear like i think
it was uh
jerome hansen who said you know this is
a great idea i look forward to watching
uh
but then
later on he he said he would have been
interested in participating same with
berta fernandez in madrid who sort of
said i don't know if i want to
participate but later on said she wanted
to participate so i mean i don't want to
have to choose who's going to be the
active participant what i would like to
do is set up circles groups that are
called circles in google plus
and have uh in each circle people who
are interested in speaking in that
language who are interested in the same
subject and who are more or less in the
same you know have indicated that these
time slots work for them and if there's
5 10 or 15 in that circle i will invite
all of those 5 10 or 15 and the first
nine people will be the ones who are
active participants so uh i would ask
you to let me know
either by commenting at the google plus
link page or commenting here let me know
if you are interested what subjects
you're interested in like is it link is
it some aspect of link is it language
language learning in general
and which languages you would want to
participate in it can be more than one
language
and roughly what time slots work for you
and if i get that information then i can
create four or five
circles and it might we might have some
of the same people in different circles
and then it makes it easier for me to
invite a whole circle
to participate
so that's one thing
and in general i look forward to your
feedback
and hope that we can do this on a
regular basis you'll notice i changed
out of my i put on a nice shirt for the
conference now that that's over and i
got to do some work around the house
here i'm back into my
more casual attire anyway look forward
to hearing from you uh bye for now